Voiceover:What I want to
do in this video is take
this quantity represented
by these greenish
emerald-looking bars, where
each bar represents one,
and try to represent them
using the digits that we know,
the digits 0, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
And the way I'm going
to do it is I'm going
to group this into tens
so I'm going to see
how many tens I have and then essentially
how many ones that I have left over,
so let's try to group
this into groups of ten.
So 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9,
Let me actually, I
messed that up, let see,
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10.
So that's one group of
ten right over there.
Let me box that off so
that i know that is ten.
So, that's one group
of ten, now let's see,
let's see if I can get a few
more groups of ten in there.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10.
That's my second group
of ten right over there.
Second group of ten and now let's see,
it looks like I got several
more groups of ten here.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10.
So that's a third group of ten,
and it looks like I might
be able to get one more,
so that's my third group
of ten and then we have,
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10.
So that's my fourth group of ten.
Fourth group of ten right over here.
So I was able to fit in
at least just this is 1,
This is a ten right over here,
This is another ten right over here.
That's the third ten, and
then that's the fourth ten.
So we can say that's 10+10+10+10.
Or all of this combined is equal to 4,
1, 2, 3, 4, tens but I'm
not done with the number,
I still have 1, 2, I
have 2 ones left over.
So this is a one, so that's
a one right over there.
And then this is another
one, so that's another one.
So I have 2 ones, so this right over here,
That is 2 ones, remember for each of these
little green bars we
said represents a one.
So this whole number is what?
What's going to be the 4 tens,
1 ten, 2 ten, 3 tens, 4 tens.
Plus the 2 ones, so
let me write that down.
So it is 4 tens plus 2
ones, but what is that?
Well if we use the number systems
that we're used to
representing, we would say,
"Well look, our number system gives us
a way of representing that."
Because the first place,
this is the ones' place
So let me gets some of this blue color,
So this is the ones' place.
There we use one of the digits,
0, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9,
To see how many ones we have.
And we have 2 ones.
And then the next place over to the left,
that's where we say how many tens we have.
That's where we say how many tens.
And we know how many tens
we have, we have 4 tens.
So the way that we would represent this
in our number systems we would say
that this was 4 tens and 2 ones.
We call this right over
here, we call this 42.
Another way that you can think about this,
is 4 tens, that's 10+10+10+10,
that's going to be 40, but once again,
we're using our number
system to represent this,
and then we have 2 ones but
I like to write it this way,
just to remind ourselves that this 4 which
represents 4 tens also represents 40.
Because 4 tens is 40.